bravo marine au vu des applaudissements
de lilian noirot pas de véritable
déception au front national à montceau
les mines mais les militants eux ne
cachaient pas leur amertume
hier soir à l'annoncé de l'élection des
manuels macro perec marine allaient
gagner oui et que notre vie voilà les
est différente et là c'est une
continuité du gouvernement sortant et on
voit là on est très déçus des prix mais
voilà je vais espoir après donc un jour
peut-être mais l'espoir fait vivre
commenté l'histoire marine le pen battu
au deuxième tour mais en saône et loire
avec un meilleur score qu'au niveau
national 38,37 % des voix contre 33 19
même les délégués cgt m'envoient des
messages désolé pour vous désolé pour la
france je suis aussi déçu que toi cette
élection présidentielle a montré une
forte progression nationaliste désormais
bien implantée particulièrement en zone
rurale il hier soir les frontistes ne
voulait pas parler de défaite on n'est
pas satisfait de la défaite bien
évidemment mais on aurait aimé donc
l'emporter mais ça laisse présager un
avenir
donc nous allons nous allons encore être
remontés à bloc et puis ce score de 34 %
quand même exceptionnel pour pour marine
seul contre compte le système coalisés
comme en saône et loire où le front
national était largement en tête au
premier tour dans l'yonne malgré la
défaite on retient surtout la formidable
progression de marine le pen c'est de
très bon augure en tout cas dans cette
recomposition politique tous les
patriotes donc se sont unis contre les
mondialistes
donc on ya le nouveau clivage qui est
qui est clair et maintenant vas que nous
nous dirigions dirigeons vers législatif
que nous allons gagner
battu à la présidentielle le front
national est prêt à livrer bataille
et